la mer la vraie cette fois avec les
levant ses falaises escarpées son port
ses pêcheurs en phase d hyères dans le
var lille à ses fidèles car à la
développer depuis 70 ans
une philosophie de vie toute simple
vivre au gnouf c'est le premier centre
européen du naturisme
jean jacques dufour et jean moulin se
sont penchés sur cette question
fondamentale site préservé et repère des
adeptes de la nudité l'île du levant
abrite l'une des plus anciennes cités
naturiste du monde héliopolis la vive du
soleil la première impression assez
sympathique qu'un peu sauvage il n'y a
pas encore de port donc ça permet encore
de garder l'authenticité et tout le
monde est là tu restes ici une grande
partie des gens sont naturistes mais
comme ils aiment y est tranquille ils
vont se mettre dans les endroits où il
ya pas beaucoup de monde parce que s'ils
sont pas tous nus non bateaux qui
arrivent de port-cros donc on évite
quand même de choquer les gens nous
prennent pour des fins la nudité le
caractère escarpés de l'endroit préserve
de l'île et hordes de touristes
on a une vue splendide par une vue
splendide vous avez là une vue
imprenable une vue imprenable de l'ide
parce que chaque à chaque coin de l'île
vous avez une vue différents thèmes là
alors c'est une vue grandiose et puis
donc à gauche vous avez là quelques
bâtiments militaires une infime partie
des bâtiments militaires
les militaires qui utilisent le terrain
pour des essais possède 90% de l'endroit
c'est très surveillé par mer et par
terre
donc si on vient avec un petit bateau
ils vont nous dire est intercepté oui la
gendarmerie vous intercepte s'est
démarqué sur les cartes et tout haut du
côté militaire au moment le grillage
s'arrête aussi passer de l'autre côté
ils arrivent mais revenons à nos moutons
des drôles de bêtes qui pensent que
quand il ya de la laine
il n'y a pas de plaisir et alors là je
voyais dans la piscine et au tour des
journaux mais si il y à ce qu'on appelle
les textiles qui viennent vous les
acceptez aussi non non non non non moi
je les ai connus
je fatigue pas surpris non plus en me
voyant qui se sauve en courant passe ils
m'ont vu ni non on a une jeune cliente
est 100% nature le naturisme et ses
règles c'était justement le sujet abordé
par ces messieurs dames des adeptes qui
en ont marre de se faire tailler des
costards la fédération que je représente
oeuvre beaucoup en ce moment sur l'image
du naturisme sur dire le naturisme et
expliquer à tous les gens qui
s'imaginent que naturisme égale sexe
c'est faux le naturisme
il est sain il est propre il est
familiale et je n'ai vraiment pas
honteux d'être naturiste moi tout ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'au début du
xxème siècle ont justifié cette pratique
en expliquant que c'était bon pour la
santé début du siècle en france sans
visa par exemple il faut donner à son
corps quatre bancs et pinder les
bardeaux évincerait ils vendent ombre en
nullité intégral
dites moi c'est mieux tout nu tout
bronzé toulouse ont bronzé
ja c'est très agréable d'être nue c'est
une complète liberté
on est plus proche de la nature qu'on se
baigne on sent rien sur sur soi c'est
vraiment extraordinaire
y'a qu'une classe et océans plages et
criques alors mais a décrit pied des
rochers il n'y a pas grand monde et
s'émerveiller pas grand monde souffre
dans la mer j'habitais là on habite sur
l'île
et alors c'est comment la vie aux
laurence et ses parts à digne preuve les
gens y vivent tenue paradis très
récemment électrifié lille mais pas un
endroit branché ici ce que l'on aime
c'est bronzer en toute simplicité
[Musique]
tonneau